today we're welcoming back an old friend
of the show
ben dixon host of the benjamin dixon
show
ben always great to have you david it's
always a pleasure glad to be back
so okay i mean how's joe biden doing so
far
you know that's a big question i
i feel like it's a loaded question but
you know if you if you actually are
dealing fairly with joe biden he's had
some good and he's had some bad
yeah i am um there are a lot of people
who are
really grateful to have the uh the
stimulus checks
um and while it wasn't as much as we
wanted it to be
and while it wasn't it didn't include 15
an hour it still
helped a lot of people and there are
some good things in it right there's uh
the the attack that they have owned
poverty right there this bill is
supposed to cut
child childhood poverty by 42 to 45
percent
we'll see how that does so i have to
give them thumbs up on that even though
it's not
everything i think is really beneficial
so one of the big things that was
missing from the stimulus bill
was the 15 minimum wage my view on this
is that the problem
is that the senate democrat the group of
senate democrats
just isn't left enough it's not that
kamala didn't
push the parliament override the
parliamentarian because
we saw with the vote that democrats just
didn't have the votes for 15
minimum wage so for me it's less about
oh
joe and kamala backed off by not
overriding
it's there aren't enough democrats in
the senate who want a 15
minimum wage do you see it that way or
do you think they should have pushed the
par
overridden the parliamentarian yeah no i
definitely think they should have
overridden the parliamentarian if for no
other reason than to
give us the fight that that we wanted
and that we needed on that issue however
you're not wrong
because then it would have been um
cursing cinema
uh joe manchin yeah and the other six
who sabotages before and and so but that
does speak to a bigger broader problem
like we
are going to have to send more
progressive leaning senators
there to get things done and they
absolutely
are going to need to overturn or abolish
the filibuster or at least
amend it if they want to get anything
done going forward yeah i want to talk
about filibuster but just to play out
the overriding
in practice we got the vote on including
the minimum wage anyway so we have a
record of who voted no
wouldn't the override just have created
the fight
but in the in the end just delayed
getting people the cash
well you know it depends on the timing
of it like it could have delayed it a
little bit further but also it would
have
it really would have shown and and again
you make a great point
we know the eight people who opposed it
um but then also it would have been it
would have been a little bit more
pressure because
at that point it could come down to a uh
it came down to the 50 vote
versus what they needed in terms of the
60. so it gives them an opportunity
to it really gave the democrats an
out in the long run and it leaves the
suspicion that
perhaps they didn't want to do it anyway
right but that's in the weeds
and like again there are a lot of people
who are just grateful to have
these checks because it took i mean
we're we're so far into this pandemic
and sixteen hundred versus two thousand
fifteen dollars an hour a lot of people
want it we can come back to it
but absolutely i mean we i'm glad they
got it done
yeah if it had not happened probably
within five to seven days of when it did
it probably goes on a list of failures
for joe biden
no absolutely because you know if the
the clock was ticking the same
you know my side of the equation we were
putting pressure on him from everywhere
like
we wanted 15 an hour and we wanted those
checks back in january
yeah you know so you know they they did
what they could do
and there's still enough good things in
that bill that i think
are going to have structural impacts
especially on childhood poverty i
i can't overestimate that or overstate
that because that's a really significant
move
and they're making they're giving us
signals that they want that to continue
even
after this bill has um run its course so
filibuster there's the option of
eliminating the filibuster
with the pros and cons that come with
that including what happens the next
time that republicans are in control
there's the idea of reform of the
filibuster like for example requiring it
to be an
actual talking filibuster rather than
popping in
and extending debate and then and then
leaving there's the idea of
you need 40 in the chamber
to do it rather than the absence of
60 keeps it going where are you kind of
coming down on this debate right now
you know i for all intents and purposes
the willingness to
even from joe manchin the willingness to
at least admin the filibuster so that it
is
at a minimum a talking filibuster um
is a positive signal however there are
just so many
impediments to the actual progress that
needs to happen immediately especially
coming from georgia
like we absolutely are going to have to
pass some type of voting rights
legislation it's gotta i know we already
have hr one in the house it's gotta pass
the senate
and the republican party absolutely
would use a talking filibuster
and they will stuff it out in order to
kill that bill
so i think while it is encouraging that
they want to amend it at a minimum
i don't know that a standing filibuster
is going to be enough
to actually beat back the uh the desires
of republicans to suppress the vote
across the country yeah i tend to agree
with you and actually this
in thinking about a lot of the possible
big
uh initiatives that joe biden is
considering so last week we heard
maybe the next big thing will be the tax
reform plan
this week we heard it might be a three
trillion dollar infrastructure plus
schools and families
um now there's a lot more discussion
about gun control
in light of the two shootings on most of
these things
i'm expecting republican support to not
be close to zero to be
literally zero given that
how should how should joe biden and
democrats even account for that in
thinking of what to approach next
no i i think they honestly are going to
have to play hardball
and of course see the the fear of the
republicans uh mitch mcconnell did
a couple of videos uh twice making
threats about what they would do
if the filibuster is abolished i think
the
response to that from democrats should
be abolish a filibuster and run campaign
ads every single day
letting americans know exactly what
republicans want to do if they ever get
back in power
so i think they're going to have to play
some serious hardball and leverage the
actual majority in this country to
ensure
that they don't get back in power in the
near future one of the things i've been
thinking about
is trying to get out of like our
politics bubble
where we follow this stuff in a way that
most people don't and thinking like for
example the debate around whether
coveted cash passes with 60 or with 50.
right no one who was waiting on the 1400
cares that it passed with 50 instead of
60 right and along the same lines when
you think about something like
gun control we know gun control is less
of a voting issue for people on the left
than it is for people on the right the
right weaponizes it whether or not joe
biden's doing anything they're saying
biden's coming for your guns either way
absolutely
uh taxation as an example the narrative
of bidens raising your taxes even if
they're not really going up for 98
of households or whatever the case may
be do you think that joe biden should be
thinking about which of his ideas
are voting issues versus which are not
or should he just be doing
what he thinks he can get done actually
that's a
really a really great question and thank
you it is 1400 versus the 1600
i i honestly think that he needs to just
simply strike
at what is going to be the best interest
of the people
because this is a really good time where
what he does that's in the best interest
for the majority of the american people
is actually really good politics even if
you do have the republicans on the other
side of the aisle who are going to
weaponize literally anything
they're going to call him a socialist
when he's far from that
they're going to say he's coming to take
their guns when he's not going to take
their guns we're talking about like a
universal background
check which you know we're talking about
issues that have like 90 approval rating
in some categories so
you know he needs to play hardball with
them and make his appeal to the american
people in a very direct way
they need to communicate it they need to
go across the country and make
sure i know we're in a pandemic but they
need to make sure they take credit for
all the good things that they're going
to do
because if they don't republicans will
will vote against it and then try to
take credit for it
so on immigration immigration to me
feels like if you watch the press
briefings and you see
how reporters some reporter even even
not right-wing reporters are
adopting the language that's been
established by republicans about
a crisis at the border we looked at the
border patrol data
seasonally this is when crossings go up
you also have some kind of
pent-up demand from 2020 where there was
very little movement because of the
pandemic so
it all seems in the range of what you
would expect seasonally
crisis to me is is the wrong word but i
think
they realize they're getting the most
traction with it and so that's why
they're continuing to go with it
kamala harris now is being put in charge
of handling
what's going on at the border what
exactly
what are the options even for what joe
biden could and should be doing there
you know in despite his
options because it is a complicated
issue and it is a matter of capacity and
the speed with which they can actually
move
particularly children through the system
and make sure the children are not there
longer than they're supposed to be there
there is a very nuanced and problematic
issue there at the border in terms of
processing and logistics there is no
crisis though and i appreciate you
stating that because
even we saw msnbc they're they're using
this language joe scarborough has
started using this language
and it is a throwback to the obama
administration when this is literally
the number one way they wanted to attack
president obama
because it does gain traction and it
plays well
with the conservative base but that goes
to the the right-wing
inherent right-wing framing that we get
from mainstream media anyway
right and the the irony of it is of
course these headlines were not
being promulgated during the trump
administration
right when the numbers i'm sure if we
look at the numbers there's going to be
some overlap in terms of comparability
but now it is a talking point because
this is all they have
this is what they're going to do and so
we need to look at the we need to
question these mainstream media outlets
that are now shifting to the same
paradigm
where they are creating a crisis with
their headlines versus the reality of
the data
yeah to me the the crisis language
that's being used
is not that different than china virus
and sleepy joe
in the sense that the way you describe
it
is what frames it even for people who
are questioning
what peter ducey says during you know
the gensake press briefings or whatever
the case may be
but for me so far if you say what's the
biggest mistake joe biden has made or
the biggest failure
it's that yes he did do the executive
order on removals and deportations
and then the texas judge said no the the
justification is no good
and biden's not done anything since when
i've read a lot of really good legal
analyses that are
biden could redo those executive orders
to stop that
with different legal justifications and
really put
courts in a position to say none of
these justifications are valid
he just did one executive order and has
kind of stepped away for now
i i don't like that that's for me one of
the biggest things i think he's done
wrong
yeah yeah i think that that would be one
of the number one things
the number two thing is the willingness
to confront the issue head on for the
difficulty that it actually is
i think jinsaki doesn't really do
a really good service to the
administration by trying to prevaricate
around the complexity of the situation
versus just simply saying
that we don't have the capacity that we
need to actually get these children
out of these cages as soon as we you
know it's just really direct language is
really necessary at this point
because if if they're for varicating too
much
then we're going to see these images and
it's not just going to be the right
there's going to be a lot of people on
the left and justifiably so because if
we see these images
we may not know the the technical
difference between what's happening
right now and what happened during the
trump administration what we see are
people in cages and i think they have to
just do the very difficult job of being
straightforward
and expanding the capacity don't just
tell us the truth
help us change the structural problems
that are underneath it one of the things
i would like to see
would be to see jen saki better prepared
to lay it out and say listen
the system we were handed was a disaster
already
we want to fix it but that will require
growing government but the republicans
are also
against that so the only way to do what
they want us to do
is by expanding resources hiring more
people
maybe in the short term having more
facilities but they also say we need
small government so
how is it that they expect it to be
fixed if we can't do any of the things
that need to be done
she doesn't she sometimes will say it's
complex but she'll never really frame it
in those terms
right so and and then trust the american
people to handle the complexity right
now i know that's asking a lot all that
is considered but have you seen the
interviews with anti-vaxx people
i know complexity is not playing well
right now well but complexity will
will do well for the people who are
actually genuinely concerned about yeah
right
you're going to have bad faith actors on
both sides of the equations that no
matter what this administration does
they're going to get attacked for it
that said there are some of us who
actually are simply concerned about
making sure that not it's not even just
about keeping promises but we're doing
the absolute best that we can
for the human lives that come and seek
asylum in this country
and so for those of us who are operating
in good faith we can handle a moment of
complexity versus
you know kind of dancing around the
issue have you been surprised by how
effective
the right-wing media apparatus and
republicans are
at getting an idea to trickle all the
way down
to what i would call random republican
voters in diners in oklahoma like when
cnn goes in and they do it they
interview diners in oklahoma or
in idaho or whatever and ideas that
start with like
you know jim jordan and lauren beaubert
and fox and friends about
either a crisis at the border or stuff
about mandatory vaccine whatever
it gets so quickly to just random
republican voters in oklahoma who just
accept it
yeah you know it's it's a continuation
of the same echo chamber that they've
mastered over the last 40 years i mean
it used to start with rush limbaugh and
now
it you know it's being regurgitated from
through social media and
on youtube like youtubers have the same
talking points
uh people on twitter have the same
talking points i mean
randoms like and here's the other side
of it uh david
you now actively have citizens through
social media
contributing to and seeking out those
talking points so that they can have
something to say to their aunt that they
don't like who's a liberal on social
media so they're they're they're
indoctrinating and propagandizing
themselves what's funny about that is
for the last at least four years but
arguably longer
the republican party has not been about
policy but it's been about preventing
the left from doing anything
and making the left look bad that's
almost the ideology now
of the random republican voter at
thanksgiving who is not so much
interested in policy but in about what
can i say
to embarrass my liberal cousin or
whatever the case may be yeah no
it's very personalized politics at this
point and it's it's
the analogy of football teams couldn't
be any truer because they're special
pleading on behalf i mean
they they don't care that it's illogical
they don't care if it's downright a lie
they just need something so that they
can post to own the libs
and uh then if it turns out that it's
disinformation not allowed on social
media
the fact that they're not allowed to
post it oh yeah it becomes part of the
story that they talk oh
yeah no absolutely there's no greater
grievance than a conservative who has
been
flagged for uh propaganda uh
that that um that will be interesting to
follow also actually
during during the biden administration
but one last thing on this i've been
thinking
okay so they want to solve cancel
culture is there any quote
solution that is not incredibly
authoritarian
uh government involvement in private
business
i i mean they're oh you mean for them to
solve exactly when they say we need to
fix cancel culture on social media
how do they imagine it being done
without regulating the hell out of these
platforms in a way that they claim to
oppose you know i think what they really
want is just to be able to use the
n-word and not get in trouble i think
that would
i think that's their standard so if you
allow that they'll
they'll forgive the other side that's
the end of cancer culture for this they
want to be able to say anything they
want to say without any responsibility
so i i mean the amount of government
that would be required
to come in to you know private
corporations
private jobs and and to manage no
responsibility for
it's just a mess thinking about it yeah
it's they want freedom from the
consequences of speech even if it's
someone else's speech that
that is the consequence absolutely we've
been speaking
with ben dixon host of the benjamin
dixon show you can
find him on of course youtube
occasionally on tyt where where else
what's your like main hub right now
would you say
i would say my main hub is uh the
podcast format is still
one of the strongest sides so anywhere
you get podcasts i heart radio
spotify all those places were there ben
always great having you on
hey thanks for having me david